Not even.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
In the first opening verses of
Allah Subhanahu Waaala prepares the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and
puts into perspective the priorities
of his da'wah, the priorities of
teaching the people Islam, the
priorities of calling people to Islam.
And one of the key things that he
mentions is
be patient for the sake of your lord.
This is an interesting thing because you
would expect that when Allah speaks
about re revelation, choosing him as a
prophet that he would tell him, you
know, celebrate. this is a a moment
for celebration. You have been chosen as
a prophet. But the next verse is be
patient.
And this falls perfectly in line with
what
with what that first of the Muslim
and that scholar of history
who told our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam that you will have enemies. You
will be fought against. You will be
tribulated. you will have tribulations
that you will go through and endure
because of bringing this message. So he
says
and you can actually see this pattern in
a number of places throughout the Quran
where Allah mentions revelation
and then he mentions patience right
after. So for instance Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says in
Indeed, we have sent down upon you the
Quran in in parts and we have sent it
down over time in segments. So be
patient. So patience here comes right
after knowledge of the re revelation.
And so right after this, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says to him
the following three verses he says, "And
so on that day when the horn is blown,"
that indeed is a day that is very
difficult
a day that is not going to be easy upon
the disbeliever.
So the first thing he mentions is
for
[Silence]
this is the horn
that will be blown into that commences
the day of judgment.
First of all, we look at the name that
Allah gives it. In some verses he refers
to it as a
in other verses this one here he
refers to it as
and
in the Arabic language is actually the
horn of an animal
that is
drilled out or hollowed out.
And usually they would use it to blow
into it as a kind of battlecry in war.
They would blow into this horn. They're
referred to in the west as trumpeteers.
They would blow into this horn and it
would be a proclamation of war. Commands
would be given to the military through
this horn etc.
in some translations and sometimes
people refer to it as the trumpet
when the trumpet is blown. This is a
less favorable translation. This is
taken from some of the wordings and
translations in the Bible. Rather, it is
a horn. It literally is a horn that is
hollowed out that will be blown into.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
referred to this horn and he mentioned
that it is a horn made of light
and it is given to one of the angels
who's named Israel
is
one of the angels that carries the
throne of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
that on the day of judgment eight
angels, eight great angels were will
bear and carry the throne of their lord
on the day of judgment. One of these
eight angels is named is
the prophet sallall.aii
said
Waspam.
[Silence]
In one narration, the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said, "Allah
has given me permission
to tell you about one of the
descriptions
of one of the angels that carry the
throne of Allah.
The distance between his earlobe and his
shoulder is the travel of 700 years.
This is an unimaginable unfathomable
you know size of creature. And so the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam gives us
this one description to kind of drive
home just how serious the day of
judgment is. This is one of the angels
that carry the throne of Allah.
In
narrates a narration that Abbas
said that the prophet Sam
said
[Silence]
In another narration, the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said that
the seven heavens and the seven earths
compared to the
which is mentioned in
which in the Arabic language is a
foottool the foottool of Allah the seven
heavens and the seven earths in the
foottool of Allah is a ring in a
vast open desert
He said, "And the foottool compared to
the throne of Allah is the size of
that ring compared to the size of that
desert." These are unimaginable things.
I mean, we can only begin to imagine
these kinds of descriptions. When
something is so big that you're not
describing it with distance or space
anymore and you're describing it with
time, this is beyond something that we
can fathom as human beings. And so this
bearer of the throne is
he has this horn that Allah gave him.
Our prophet tells us that it was made
out of light.
In one narration
collected in a
said, the prophet Sam
said,
[Silence]
He says
that in one narration he said, "How can
I
find it in myself to enjoy enjoy the
pleasures of the life of this world.
Whilst I have the knowledge
that the
angel of Allah who has been commanded to
blow into the horn, he was given the
horn and he is waiting right now for the
command of Allah to blow into it and to
essentially blow this entire existence
into oblivion.
In another narration collected by on the
authority of Abi, the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said
[Silence]
He said
in another narration that the angel
Israel
from the moment he was given the horn
and told that he was going to blow into
the horn when Allah commands him has not
blinked his eyes from that moment. His
head is bowed and he is staring towards
the throne of Allah
because he is afraid that he will be
commanded to blow into the horn before
he is able to blink and reopen his eyes.
His eyes are staring intently and
tentatively
two very bright stars. This is how
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
described is we all might think to
ourselves, what do you mean he's
waiting, not blinking his eyes since
then? Thousands and thousands and
thousands of years have passed by.
This all is predicated on the idea on
the notion that the angel of death, the
angels of Allah, they all experience
time we do here
in the heavens. Time for us, it goes by
this, seconds for the angels
in the heavens. It's it's just a few
minutes for them. You notice if you read
the narration
of the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam,
you can go to Bkari a Muslim read these
narrations where the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam speaks
about the night of al- mar
and he speaks about that when ji took
him to the first heaven.
Gabriel then asked that the gate be
opened for him. And he said, "Who is
with you?" The gatekeeper of the first,
"Who is with you?" He said, "Muhammad is
with me." And the angel, the gatekeeper
said,
"Has he already been sent as a
messenger?"
What does that mean? This was how many
years after he was a prophet and
messenger?
10 years. Because
was in which year? after
the 10th after prophethood
10 year the 10th year after prophethood
was
but the angels in the heavens they're
not experiencing time that it
hasn't been t 10 years for them and so
when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam arrived with gi to the first
heaven he said
has he already been sent they knew he
was going to be sent. But has he already
been sent? Why? This is nothing but a
few minutes. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
he says, subhanahu wa ta'ala they
perceive the hour to be very far away.
Yet we perceive it to be very near.
Subhanah.
And so for us this is a long time
but to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to the
angels of the heavens this is a mere few
seconds and that's why sometimes you
know there are silly questions that a
person will ask and these questions are
based on that misconception for
instance they will say
two people are dying in two very far
places from each other on the earth. How
is it that the angel of death at the
exact same moment goes to take the soul
of this one and that one at the same
exact time? Yeah, sure. Same exact time
for us for the angel of death. This this
question is all based on what? The idea
that the angel of death and the angels
of Allah, they perceive and experience
time we do here on this earth. And
that's why people will say that the
disbeliever's way of thinking is I want
a quick death.
When I die, I want to die real fast. I
want it to just be over fast. But the
prophet sallall.aii Wasallam was
narrated to have said
he said
that the the surprising quick death is a
very sad tragedy that occurs to a person
because they don't have time to fix
things before they pass away. And we
think that the person is dying right
away. say, "Well, you know, he didn't
suffer." How do you know that? How do
you know that he didn't suffer? For us,
it was a moment. Perhaps it was a
thousand years for this person. How can
we know that? In order to know that,
you'd have to either have revelation
from Allah telling you that or you will
have had to have died yourself, gone and
seen it, and then come back to tell us
about it. Neither of which has occurred.
this belief that you know the laws of
physics are the laws of physics
everywhere. We can't even prove that the
laws of physics that apply to the stars
in the sky for us. We can't prove that.
Scientists cannot prove that. They
cannot prove that a thousand years ago
the laws of physics are exactly the same
as they are now. It's an unprovable
thing.
And so this is where the place that
these kinds of questions come from.
[Arabic recitation]